هي سيده وعلى قيد الحياه والجميع هنا صفق
حينما اخرجوها يتم الان يعني هي على قيد
الحياه مئه بالمئه ميسون وهي سيده نعم كما
تحدثنا من قبل الان يعني ساحاول
نعم ميسون هي سيده والجميع هنا يعني كانت
فرحه عامره صراحه حينما اخرجوها يتم الان
نقلها ميسون الى سياره الاسعاف
نعم هي ميسون شابه وهي مستيقظه تماما
ويعني تحرك شفتيها
وعيونها بشكل طبيعي مئه بالمئه نحن نتحدث
عن شيء عظيم جدا نعم
كنت ذكرت انه امراه مسنه وربما ابنتها
معها هل هي الابنه هذه التي خرجت التي
خرجت شابه ليست ربما في الثلاثين لا اعتقد
ان كانت يعني هي التي كان مقصود انها على
قيد الحياه ولكني اعلم بان هنالك سيده
وابنتها التي خرجت للتو من تحت الانقاضي
يا شابه وهي مستيقظه مئه بالمئه وانا
رايتها تحرك شفتيها ربما تتحدث بشيء وتحرك
اعينها بشكل طبيعي مئه بالمئه هذا اليوم
الثالث لها تحت الانقاض ميسون وهذا شيء
يبعث على الامل بشكل كبير هذه السياره
التي تتواجد فيها السيده التي تم انقاذها
للتو طبعا
منذ ساعتين يعملون على اخراجها من تحت
الانقاذ كانوا اكتشفوا انها على قيد
الحياه ميسون بعد ان سمعوا صوتا وهم هذه
هنالك حاله اغماء على ما يبدو انها من
اسره
يعني انا راح يغمى علي بس شفت المنظر
هذه حاله اغماء هذه حاله اغماء للسيده
تنتظر يعني حينما علمت ان ان هذه السيده
على قيد الحياه ربما اصيبت بنوبه
امل وفي المقابل يعني فقدت الوعي ربما
كذلك افسر الامر لانه هي
صعب ان اشرح لك كم كم يعني المشهد مؤثر
جدا الجميع هنا
ذهل فعلا لانه كان الاحباط والياس قد
تغلغل للجميع بانه لا يمكن ان يخرج احد
على قيد الحياه خصوصا اننا في اليوم
الثالث ولكن هذا شيء عظيم جميل جدا ربما
يبعث الامل للالاف في العامه